because I hear that juries podcast we
just women are I don't think better what
harmonized sounded like a magic to me
I'm gonna you got hurt
I got sounded
welcome back into general podcast
Wow when you're drying your joint this
is actually on mother's day we're
recording we are joined by happy
Mother's Day to all the mothers out
there you wonder if you love you hey hey
did you use
speaking of Mother's Day this episode of
the generative podcast was brought to
you by lift right now guys want you to
start driving get your mother that's a
great job if your mother needs to go
somewhere call her a lift the best
ride-sharing service to right now you go
to list con that's ly ft.com Faustina
Julian you need a five hundred dollar
new driver Boehner's say you're looking
for new drivers right now so you and
your mom co-star Devon for left any
mother also brought to you by tracker
never lose your items again tracker is a
tiny coin size device that you can put
on your wallet phone keys or on your
other wallet or other your other phone
or on your other keys so you don't lose
them ever again go to tracker commas tra
CA are calm and use promo code and
Julian and you get a free tracker
problem with every order kill you hail
you thank you sponsor thank you so much
left but I don't know if you've noticed
this or not yet but I like to leave my
minion blanket in here so that I can use
it whenever we're doing this people are
like I love Oh Jenna just doesn't give a
[ __ ] anymore because I'm working and I'd
like to know when it was that you gave a
[ __ ] yeah that's a good question I
literally never have I wasn't there but
on a ladder that you think it is there's
no point of reference
I always seen it enough my giving drugs
and for me it's been kind of a long time
ejector
Julian I have it right
Yeah right in China them teeth are like
dr. Phil fan dude what a fake chocolate
I love you very much but you do we love
using your own song it's your automated
by it's better than a better day to buy
songs you just laugh at me but I heard
less she wants her yeah no that's fun
babe I'm sure anyways how are we doing
today well before we got in here we had
quite the wonderful Mother's Day we had
all the mothers here we had surveillance
was on deck yeah we had my mom and my
grandma and mimosas on deck we had salad
on deck but not bad kind of salad
there's like a delicious sea just now
that we made a delicious chili and make
delicious well thank you yeah it's been
fun so we're just we're hanging out and
we figured what a better day to have the
data machine back on the podcast you
haven't been on since the episode in
Toronto we're talking about those
stories those 100 stories you know I'm
kind of that last October yeah yeah so
you are well overdue for another
appearance here and one of you suggested
I figured I should probably find it on
Twitter to give you what did you
suggested this I tweeted out what we
should do and someone said Jenna trivia
daddy versus Julian why are you making
fart noises like oh it's Gina Gina paid
off girl
well I'm sorry Jenna Jenna yeah Debbie
whistling so basically doing it the idea
is Jenna compiled trivia questions about
her and her laugh and it's going to be
me versus Evie on figuring out who knows
more they're not really that trivia II
well we'll see I guess we'll see I think
you'll leave that up to us right I
expect to kick your ass myself
so on it is so on getting ready know
I've known her a lot longer than you
have
I think it not a lot of you know me I'm
telling you know her give or take 20
years mmm I didn't know where the first
step it's interesting though you
definitely have that you have the time
lunging yeah you got a longevity on me
but I but I see her a lot more often now
and uh you know I feel like I feel like
I I'll get you on some of these it's a
good well we'll see I think we will see
by the way I like your pins
thank you know where you got it but I
really like yeah yeah she just makes me
a waffle head oh your waffle waffle hat
is that the name of the fan base for
that ten I don't know but I liked how I
put it on the hop I see I see so there
was a puma jacket but instead of the
Puma head and it's now a waffle what you
don't like the starvation I was kind of
like I like it I like it almost go ahead
she says well I think only delighted to
hear that she'll call the Oh call
alright so let's get into this okay so
waste no more time let's get right into
it alright so I have 35 questions oh my
god I'm sick of this how many we get
does not in every defecate I do all
right question number one what did I
want to be when I grew up circa third
grade ish to be first one are mmm mmm
wait wait wait I don't think that's fair
see before asking like should it be
whoever answers first or like she can't
answer first because she's known me
longer you have to answer first
okay fine makeup artist okay mom what's
your answer struck a third grade what
did I want to be the very concrete
answer a circus clown
wow this is going to be a bloodbath um
the answer is a safe question you
brought it and wrote it in a little book
in it I wanted to its hand written by me
it says I wanted to be either a
professional soccer player or a
zookeeper
woo no you are right about
yeah wait how do you sizes know if you
wrote in your private book you don't
have access I've it was published yeah
the publisher or the seller their guns
at Kundra hey I know you're the book
tour was it because when I wasn't
thinking Oh second as a makeup artist
was it's actually pretty good yeah but I
was older than 13 oh but then you were
told it wasn't real my dad would have
been it wasn't a real job
yeah we've come to Hollywood yeah oh my
god and you still want to be a zookeeper
so well yeah that's good she wants to be
a zookeeper exception she wants to do to
become her house I just wanna I don't
want to go to the zoo I want nowhere I
didn't and don't who I met you know you
continue I would like to be captive if I
come home from my next trip and there's
maybe a I don't think anyone would
really be surprised she family gets out
a friend or maybe a frog just put me in
the enclosure with them okay
just feed food through the bars is that
a zookeeper that means you live at the
zoo right well I wasn't thinking of it
like that you do they very correct I
thought you took just meant you were
going to have a zoo at your house not
lovely assorting they were if I can't
have them at my house I'd like to just
live in their enclosure on the other
words could you do who the giraffes have
a nice enclosure to as I do it well
frankly I don't know what would stop you
so what is the law all right question as
a dog barking is that what they're
children
okay question number 70 gonna sue what
is my favorite game knockout like in
basketball when each other knock them
all out of those uh yeah horse horse
when you throw the basketball up and
then you can make it in you get an H you
guys know I'm asked at basketball right
my favorite game is Elder Scrolls Oh
what other schools trying how did you
blow this question
sorry I thought it was knockout I
thought you played knockout with your
friend's mom
his name was John right he lived two
houses down from us who's married to
Shaheen she was Iranian he had one hand
he taught me how to play basketball
did he play knockout no he taught me how
I was like that's what he said hold it
with this hand and punch it with your
other hand basketball I'm not kidding
I'm acid basketball partly because John
taught me how to play basketball my
father would never never let me play
with him he brothers telling everybody
he's actually not he's actually he's six
five and just not get it basketball now
well he's got the right spirit but oh my
god Wow oh that was finally done okay
it's closed for the day at least you've
got back a break I can see some got
knockout and hundreds it runs Alex
Carlisle I know something wrong with
y'all what was the last time you saw me
play knockout I thought you were playing
it the other day with that not knockout
or were you just doing your makeup I
don't know I couldn't tell
oh I can't keep up anymore all right
so far I thought you meant when you were
in the third grade yeah me too I was
still thought when you mentioned third
grade in the first I thought that was
the whole game like all these questions
okay no no one's gotten the question
right yet all right
what question number three what is my
personal favorite hair color that I've
had whoo which one was my favorite
brown gray so good guess it was purple
the purple was my favorite purple I
think brown was a good guess hmm I was
born with brown hair I thought that's
why it was your favorite
uh yeah you know first off I have to
tell me that Debbie's trying to throw
this what makes you think that
brown hair is like a slew of rainbow
colors yes it's like one of the only
human colors that I was born with I
liked I guess like where her head that I
think she's trying to throw it alright
one more give me one more try you have
35 questions only one more chance stuff
and everyone else is it log off I know
is that any color in univis Julie said
gray and that was closer than that
alright question really oh my god it's
plush in Kermit's middle name I told
this one mmm what is it she can go first
one song
Julian why cause the Begum I don't want
to be not a gentleman
um Hamilton Washington mom you're right
the answer is Washington Sherman
Washington Lincoln wait she said
Washington yeah his name is karma at
Washington Lincoln Lincoln is laughing
yeah
how did he get that laughing just his
name so his last name isn't Maureen yeah
it's Lincoln it would be like him and
it's Charles Frank no no no that's
number five Oh Franklin is the
elementary school I went to when I was
younger mom which marvels no mean
[Music]
Washington I went to Franklin Elementary
so mom died I already it's frankly Oh
Franklin
good job I try not to blow that one wow
you guys are tied somehow tied in
mediocrity
just sitting there together this is fun
I love this okay question number six
what is my favorite food
Pass or press
is accepted eggs
I can't even not do that I think I was
trying to think of uh not that's sure
whether you like it or not that's the
answer but it is your favorite food so
make sure it's not egg
I better vegan for like maybe three
years well okay but before veganism you
literally only ate eggs only only wait
can you elaborate on why you think my
favorite food we're assuming passed was
eggs around no no no why were they my
favorite food not wire edge egg well
because you could do so many things with
them that's why they were my favorite
food servers are you a baby like you to
always eat them you love eggs I always
made you a note you need to give me some
concrete evidence that eggs were ever my
favorite food
maybe it worked picking is a guessing
game mom I feel like you're throwing
this on purpose do you really think I
would do something like that one food
that I didn't even care for what I was
eating meat and stuff like that like
they always go to see out is it kind of
gross I used to like scrambled eggs when
I was a kid but like it had to be like
super dry like almost naughty I'll tell
you story about your daughter and eggs
when I think it was Valentine's Day for
her birthday one one important day for
her I woke up at like 8:00 a.m. and I
had this idea that I wanted to make her
the best scrambled eggs in the world so
I'm and I sat down and research Gordon
Ramsay's egg recipe of how he made
legs and its extent like this is uneasy
yeah right in the pan and make know this
is like it's very meticulous
I shot there I actually had to go to the
first one didn't really work out second
one I clean the fan and try it again and
they were fluffy and delicious you put
like butter and that is the way you cook
it you cooking in the saucepan you am
constantly sir so I brought it to you
for positive for bed like bed and
breakfast it's like happy birthday or
something awesome does that you're like
thanks can I get it in the kitchen in a
second you come in the kitchen and just
like take two bites he's like I'm full
like no you're not he's the whole thing
paint hated them hated them and they
were they were like probably the best
eggs I ever made
man that's how much she likes I say
we're vom okay well we don't need it we
don't need it but I have really loved
you for making them mmm I was very it's
like one time when me my brother were
kids we made for Mother's Day actually
confesses we made my mom eggs and toasts
in bed and we didn't really cook the
eggs at all so we were brought over and
it was so like raw and met me thank you
okay now for Mother's Day mommy's gonna
eat breakfast in bed alone thank you
guys going right okay mom's gonna enjoy
your breakfast made without her I think
she totally shut that [ __ ] in English
bad choice yeah I mean you didn't I we
didn't know you know they're like little
kids cooking eggs yeah so we didn't know
that she could get sick from just eating
raw eggs we were like we tried we cooked
him a little both on the pan is done
basically done so it was a thought -
yeah not the iPod the answer okay first
I thought or the egg okay so thanks
family thing did you know did you take a
guess I won't my favorite but I guess
present well guess um so but using a
past David food it's not your favorite
comfort yeah well there's multiple
answers yes current yeah current I'll
accept anything that I deem worthy of
currencies morning I know you used to
love your ham and cheese sandwiches
that's champ
currently day a vegan box mac and cheese
maintained a really
amen it's not eggs it's not actually am
you in that round thank you so much for
my big dark go round the round I was
good argument cuz you that's not wrong I
mean in theory is honor well actually it
is wrong there oval very rough okay
question number 7 my god are we not at
ten yet there's no one left listening I
assure you then name one of my childhood
pets any of them any childhood pet cheek
you are throwing the game you made aunt
named teeth no yes I'll get her name was
Anita personal oh you're wrong even at
nine she was an effete that's a and I do
all you know it was a pin know how many
guinea pigs two hamsters who we have
twenty name one there was no Jake I
thought that ants name was Jake okay
that doesn't count
name an animal name a man a small mammal
that we had growing up gained jump
oh no climb okay yes I will accept climb
first I mean I'm sort of a gray areas no
your third guess but yes climb is the
correct endler and that was Devin's
hamster you're a poop hamster hamster
terrible pain oh actually right gerbil
no actually I don't remember but she got
pregnant and she had all the babies and
then she ate them and we thought it was
a Bonnie it's true and they lived
happily ever dead alright Julian what do
you got Oh Dylan yes I will accept Dylan
Dylan was my favorite she lived for
seven years
she's pretty good hi you guys both sort
of did well she's a little bit mommy
there is no [ __ ] Jake
there is Jake I'm almost positive okay
you're throwing this on purpose
okay I'm standing question number eight
what sports did I play in high school
mmm how much time you got did I love the
list all room because only three
softball preseason softball that's to
diving
I mean tree and host season diving
that's for bowling bowling ball Tech
bowling ball physics mom what's your
answer
I got nothing you got a no I did it than
that you have to answer though what
sports that I play in high school
chasing boys okay no I had to blink on
all of hi oh you know what sports that I
play in high school them you have to
answer so that deep-sea diving
see in a way you did boken diving jump
in the water you're in the where yarder
could be in the sea it could be in the
ocean well technically you were on the
swim team so you're not wrong okay
you're in the swim team yeah divers are
on the swim team
is that how it sort of like like a
halftime show is this or like how the
this [ __ ] there's like one track and
field event that really isn't track and
field and then the rest of them are like
running their ass off and they're like
I'm on the track and field team yeah
it's like that again we also have swim
meets like a track meet you really
there's not really an event it's a meet
because we're all there to just track
and field for the end probably subtract
you need attraction or field where they
say and turn off what was the question
okay so my mom clearly loses because she
said deep-sea diving so Julian
congratulations are
he took them all so I think it's
impossible for us a because I'll answer
and then the answer is done shall I
answer no never chica dance she can
still answer and have a different and/or
the maintenance we need a buzzer system
right we should have a but I asked you
that before and you were like no we'll
both answer and then it was ever right
wins but she just wanted to say deep-sea
diving for whatever reason are you ready
for the Machine discussion or not this
is attacking how many rosaries did I use
to say a day and mark them off on my
calendar to make my rosary turn gold how
many you lay what do you want to answer
first that's up to you guys how many in
anything I don't really remember um and
I'm quite concerned for you that you
actually did this yeah how many a day
I'm going to say ten Julie seven or 12
pick a number
no it's no those are both of my answer
well my mom's right its Pat Dean
while is it was 7 or 12 I'd say 10 rows
or is a day from mark and I tell the
story
I already did I told it in the video a
long time ago
yeah all right we had a religious
teacher religion whatever is called
teacher that told us that if we said the
Rosary enough times the return cult sly
so just sit there and say 10 rosaries a
day I figured that was a good amount
kids never turn gold now
that's pretty misleading English yeah it
was plastic and I made it myself so
there wasn't really a high probability
of it turning I mean they're not a
physics teacher okay they're just trying
to encourage you to do something well my
favorite part of that story is they said
that same teacher told the same thing to
your brother and he told your father and
you felt my dad caught him saying the
rosary and he's like what are you doing
in Devlin's like I'm saying the rosary
but you know our religious teacher said
if you said it enough times are rosary
to our goal of my dad's like for God's
sake go pray over the car that's funny
that's like that's that shitty
watercolour - yeah [ __ ]
what is my drink of choice
I think I know this but is it a drink or
is it a okay whatever is in your cup mom
what's your answer I'm gonna say my mom
so if that's what's in front of you
Julian's right the answer is whatever's
in my country well I'm right too because
that's what's in your goal oh right
[Applause]
okay question number what is the name of
my master's degree I got into my
master's degree in it to read it off
like in the language in this into
language that I said what four years
[ __ ] I like don't even know I don't
think that's it oh I don't think that's
what's on there I'm gonna say pastors of
science sports psychology mom what's
your answer masters of counseling I mean
you're both correct variable around
sports psychology and counseling masters
of sport psychology and counseling from
the School of Education so even that is
a science so you don't know sign I don't
think this all began it doesn't work the
same as a bachelor so you don't get a
bachelor's of science or arts it's like
a masters of sport psychology you know I
mean it's not either or science or art I
think understood okay Congrats on my
brother was right on that chair is kumoi
day summa [ __ ] laude magna [ __ ] laude
didn't make me look like mm-hmm up might
be guessing I thought and sad I don't
remember I'm gonna say sumach Magra
dananananana join me right yeah I'm
still impressive
and I wasn't quite soon because I still
had to have part-time jobs you know yeah
how many piercings do I have woohoo
count my shallots know one two three
four five six seven eight
definitely warn your belly button you
know T so have your husband survive No
please can you do it please please I'm
trying to win this contest I'm going to
I'm going to say six so for I have seven
right in between our guesses no that
would be sighs I have double holes
double double lobes my tragus oh my
conch and then this high cartilage of
several other dead loads
the floor is pretty low doing it depends
where you're sitting you look at my face
like every day I don't count the holes
in it do you count the holes in my face
how many holes are in my face out if you
can't go okay how many tattoos do I have
to Julian just came out actually how
many tattoos yes you're born I only have
one mom and it's your initials only what
happened man I gave it to reduce a baby
[Laughter]
boy dude you're in Michelin I told you
any guy called you it's like mama and
getting your initials tattooed on me I
know what it made me feel so it is a
sweet tattoo it is very wait if I had to
what would the other one be what do you
mean it would be a full pound of cookie
on your shin here yeah yep it's gone way
back here today
a queer lower back on your lower back
but it's way down they have a transom
and you know no go and then it's it's a
little tiny one it's microchip of a
microchip
yeah you didn't know we're like a dog
well she's a special kind of human
that's just my god okay anyways wait
don't you have a tattoo on like your
inner arm that said lift calms faster
than Julie oh my yeah I find it and
right now lift is looking for new
drivers that means you can drive for
lift lift coms last Jenna Julian right
now you get a five hundred dollar driver
bonus list is great guys you can earn
hundreds of dollars per week and Express
fail if you cash out instantly you don't
to Lake days or even weeks to get your
money and lyft allows you to earn tips
within the app and you keep 100% of the
tips so right now take the guesswork out
of being a rideshare driver and go to
lift calm / generally that's Elwha FTOs
Austin and Julian happy drivers mean
happy customers maybe that's why nine
out of ten lifts rise get a perfect
five-star rating
so be a part of this it's really office
you can pick your schedule if you're
between jobs or you have weird hours you
can hop in the rider mode or a driver
mode and you have a couple people around
make some money and then go feed
yourself with that money go to lift con
la Santa Julian and you have $500 new
driver bonus limited time only so act
fast people also can I get Cayuse say
that I love lifts and there's a lot of
female drivers and I'm really happy
because if I'm by myself I'd love time
to show the fabula about yoga she can't
face I let the team out and they are
looking for more females as well that
mean I love pink well but I agree with
you it is nice so they have similar
values tend to become you know more
mellow more mellow they have
conversations with other people it's
really nice and you know what I think
the last thing you want to do in the
lift is leave your phone in the lift
lose it so put a tracker on your phone
right now yeah or your wallet tracker
calm that's tra cker calm your wallet
your phone your keys you don't have to
lose these things anymore it's a tiny
coin size device no no bigger than a
quarter and it activates be a GPS you
attach to your keys any item that you
can you feel like you lose I put it in
my drone bag I put it in my gear bag any
time I travel just in case I lose it I
go on my phone on the app and I can find
it via GPS right now tracker pixel even
comes with powerful LED lights so you
can find your stuff no matter how dark
it is which is incredibly you know you
are very smart and you know what you can
try it out right now and you get a
30-day money-back guarantee just place
the tracker on whatever device you tend
to lose and have no more stress about it
you won't lose your stuff anymore and if
you do you'll find it back right now go
to tracker comets tra CK are calm slash
nothing just trap it up and then enter
promo code generally you get a free
tracker Bravo with your order Thank You
sponsors thank you sponsored yeah yeah
I'm gonna track her tracker tracker
tracker good stuff alright I need 50
what is my favorite Nintendo 64 game
Mario I agree with her because that's
the only game you won't play with me
because it's not intended 64 dananana
you're both wrong it's chameleon twist
no you know even if it was a Mario game
it'd be Mario Party chameleon to a No
yeah chameleon twist literally no one
I've ever met who's ever played it
except for me and Devon I've heard of
community twist but I've definitely not
I didn't know you played it still be
still playing no I gave my Nintendo 64
away a long time don't you get her in 64
I don't know anything about I can't
believe you're play that game Thank You
familias
every birthday I would blow my candles
out and wish for blank
I'll fire truck weight like a real like
a twice truck
punch one the fire truck to drive up
like a real uh-huh
I think probably the probably
well-meaning like she seems to be
reacting as if you I guess she won she
wouldn't wish that anymore but when she
was little solution so how many
birthdays did this last for just finally
so it's having a great time just guess
one trillion uh what did you wish for
as a birthday wish for your for more
pets trillions right really mom you are
terribly horribly wrong violently right
I wish is for a fire truck well must
have been your brother out one of them
we are different people
not according to face app it's not
according to face out your face right
you're the same so you're saying you
would have wished for a dog for
everything everybody yes and I literally
said that earlier today ok very employer
friend a view today it's Mother's Day
shouldn't force me that's chance I got a
day off question are seventeen what was
my first real job I'm not sure which me
my real yeah what is it
like I had to go somewhere yeah file
taxes for it oh I designed paperwork for
it Wow not like babysitting you know I
mean not like watching someone else's
pet let's try this theory answer on
three let me say it out loud okay same
time ready on three one two three panel
on you guys think my first I was a
tanning salon I said a salon I didn't
say attaining what salon the place where
you had to clean tone fingernail my mom
is correct that place is called ondrea's
I was in fresh shop I was like 14 I
think and they paid me six dollars an
hour which was legendary for 40
after school and filed taxes our year 14
yeah well I had to like sign paper they
can't just tell you under the table
Thank You agent the best way to do it
but no that's illegal was fun okay you
really think my first job was
entertaining saw him when I was 22 years
old thing before that I didn't know how
old you are you were right if you had
just said salon I should have just shot
a lot of him question number 18 she
loved standing so much oil I don't
anymore I only do spay oh I'm not out
here and like I did the Sun one time and
them all wrinkly from it main a hidden
talent that I have okay what you got
girl well many people don't know this
about you okay am I going to be
embarrassed I don't want go ahead do I
care
I know you don't you look good in any
hat whoo that's true okay I don't know
if it's a talent but that is the truth
that any hat I want you to meet we used
to play that only or little not like
that does that look good on Jenna and
then she put it on me she's like
it's cute right we would go to the
department or like some big department
stores in Manhattan would look here's
the ugliest looking at me no one would
look like this that you put on her head
you look adorable and it was just a fun
game it's basically just trying on half
I know I want you I think that's the
talent though but I'll accept that
answer
okay I think you're pretty interesting
cuz you do a good enough because you
tell me your wrist
that's you I think that's definitely
hidden down don't tell me that's not I
didn't cook that way and the other way I
do like this we know I knew it this way
oh my god but then he can do it no you
can't and he had you at the top oh my
god dar was not ready for that
Dennis Dennis that I can also do this
instead so what was the one you were
thinking of no I wasn't thinking
anything I just wanted to know if he
knows me if I hadn't hated that sorry
why does that so go graphic now stop it
right now okay question number 19 I
desperately wanted to be on the
television show when I was growing up
what show was that a cancer on three one
two three Jeffrey what'd you say
mom you didn't answer family feud
no mom you know this answer I heard yes
this is how I know you're drawing this
game you I know you're drawing this game
the answer is the price is right Eric I
love Julian I wanted to feel special on
--ts me to invest you've actually
succeeded I feel special that I'm
sitting next to the machine that's yeah
Anand don't we all alright question
number two what is my astrological sign
[ __ ]
[Music]
bird Peugeot Peugeot wondered what is
what is that it's the V for Virgo
Oceanside also your answer I am a Virgo
that is correct I have a quick I want to
run a quick test daddy we saver go into
the mic and I'm going to say we're going
to my mic and you guys tell me which
sound quality is better you go first
Jericho Virgo I feel like her mic is
better than ours sorry would never raise
it with you spectacular quality of my
voice
[Music]
okay question number 21 what is my
birthstone that's me just answer that
Virgo
Jillian oh no no no no it's it's an
actual the gem so I got you where didn't
I get you on Unicode everyone I don't
know
is it an opal it's a green one I thought
as the same thing when I went you got
you that ring I said what is the what is
the September the the diamond and
what is the September diamond yeah and
they gave it to me I didn't know the
name of it I just got it what is the
cause the green one right mom do you
have an answer I thought it was an opal
but I was it okay what give me your
final answers that's not how this where
it first asked me Julian your final
answer is not Virgo that is not its own
turquoise okay that's a legit alleged
answer in your imperial opal
it's a sapphire fire it's not green it's
blue it's on this ring right here laughs
I know I that's all I got you I know
it's like you would know that I really
literally walked with her brother bird
I'm in September I want that arm it that
was seriously not just for emphasizing
when they handed me the ring I handed
them some money and then that was it I
was really sweet Julie's really sweet
all right I am ready you win I would be
shocked if you gave you know this good
what was my first AOL screen name oh
come on they have a [ __ ] - I had fun
fact I actually shared it with my
brother
we shared a screen that's this evening
yeah well it was we shared an account so
we shared a screening I'm gonna sing um
Snoop what's your answer I don't have
any so I have no very dosuk okay you're
better off yes there is Paco 300 kindly
didn't know that o7 native that little
300 I don't know why or whatever but we
I would log on we've we'd friend each
other you know like a nail oh and you
could add friends and we each have our
friends so like when I would sign on
someone to be like hey Devin I'm like oh
it's Jenna right now sorry but you might
say later easily I mean we never did
that go share in the count theory all
right Paco was his friend nickname Oh
which friend I don't remember high okay
Mike seemed like she really wanted to
know
I knew she did it what is my favorite
Disney movie hmm woman a Little Mermaid
a little marine don't you switch up
Expedia no you can't do that you just
watch on the plane that's the only
reason you answer that no not true how
many times have you heard me sing be our
guests and [ __ ] all that [ __ ] you
said you sing to cry you know we're not
doing this happy day
nice question got one full of little
people I what you shaking up to okay
fine it was me either don't you okay so
fine here here yeah here's what I have
to say that put your favorite movie
change my oh your favorite Disney movie
was needing to be smiley so let me take
you to be doing it because I don't want
it no no no no no no I want to fight no
no no the first one is the only one in
my mind I want to see the Broadway show
I don't want to see the new movie I
don't see no the Disney one here's the
one and that's yet it's get I don't want
to see a live-action guest dog he's dead
okay the Beast killed him
he fell off the clip I only want to see
cartoon guy stunt and that's it there is
no guess off everywhere you go see
beauty for me I will I'm taking your mom
fine I'll watch the Disney wanna learn
like three times over because it's only
like 70 minutes should okay question
number 20 bar person on the Internet I
love the most loved the most stuff
Brian here early and salomina who if
it's not that I swear who is it what are
your answers you need finally I said
right over here okay you you're both
right totally but the answer was Ryan
Higa
cuz Julian is assumed come on oh it's
assumed now hey you know you're not
going to be in a decently but it's
assumed mm it's okay all right of you
that's like
except Ryan injured so he's my favorite
person to it outside of you also come on
actually no Greg is my favorite personal
unit on very good elements okay question
number 25 number 25 yeah we know that I
have a scar on my hand right here I fell
off a what and got it bicycle final
answer I'm gonna say bike bicycle - yeah
is that when you killed squirrel
you murdered order murderer the answer
is destroyed and where the [ __ ] we're in
Costa Rica and I fell off of our
whitewater raft oh I forgot and sliced
my hand open and it's caught like
straight-up gangrene not really not
really but it was like very infected and
I worry about that I didn't really care
so I don't remember ever getting medical
treatment I just remember watching it
turn green and then going away that one
it was anyway block out that whole thing
yeah for what you guys are just saying
question number 26 one time I ran over a
blank on a bicycle can you appreciate
that she just like casually called you a
murderer good we could names like you
don't know that he's dead he just got
cut in half Omar sure well I'm psychic
because I knew the squirrel was going to
come up in the next question so I just
can you do we just answered a little
earlier yes those nice we don't know we
said 27 he's still alive he's the first
girl to ever get cut in half and went
forever okay number 20 name a song I
know all of the words to be our guest
two can play this game we got you mom oh
happy birthday local and you know it we
got you dude
[Laughter]
mom come on okay bye now
you know what fine you want to play that
way fine I'll plays well I did I just
got lit up I think this looks pretty
good
okay leave a pet peeve of mine like
something that I hate hmm that's
something that I hate me pick it up on
three one two three leaving paper towels
on the counter oh oh yeah lady details
on the corner yeah how does a people
that wear high heels in airports but
allege is also true you're both right
you both which what if there was a
high-heeled person from an airport came
in your house and left paper towels on
your channel smack yeah what happened it
we're hearing one yeah something
happened
okay question number 28 my high school
mascot was blank
oh that's not fair because I know that
one well some of them you can get some
of them Julian can get pretty chilly air
Moorea yeah mom what's your answer well
it's called a barren
okay Julian do you have an answer uh
high school mascot yeah Fox sorry
one of us is like sitting on the cord so
timid answer that ah not that she gets
barren yes um oh it's right there
alright what is it there we go ah very
um no the Bears right right nurse it was
the Barons way to shoot berenstain bears
I said the Baron scheme err conspiracy
Illuminati confirmed in your face
checkmate atheist so it was a barren
whatever that is there look like like
what rich landowners that's a little
miracle at football games a rich like I
just know I won't like like I would
catch for I was blocking so this symbol
was like a top hat and gloves oh yeah it
was pretty large yeah whatever
mmm okay
my favorite constellation look up stars
is what one two three
relevancy up here mom okay yeah oh
that's a condiment not a can you lose
that round you guys I'm loving this
whole [ __ ] lunch okay what's the most
I think I've ever dead lifted that's a
that's a good I actually haven't got a
clue I think if I remember correctly
because I don't know how to preserve
remember I have no clue so I'm going to
say 50 pounds 175 yeah that's right
around there like one I think is almost
$200 okay yeah I'm not sure if I hit 200
or not she started dating me just start
dead lifting crazy
but it was not fifty pounds hey well you
know I was supposed to tell that was a
bad caster yeah okay sorry bats but it's
okay it's better than relish Kevin looks
oh I also better than Jake the ant well
you did have an ant what's the most
amount of complete softball games I
pitched in college in the 6-day times
then we had like four games a day four
times six 24 - maybe six you sat out -
18 can I have the question again please
the most amount of complete softball
games that I pitched in a span of six
days I'm going to say 4 is 11 practices
yeah where we could we never had 4 games
a day we only have had 2 so good oh just
double headers each day right you can't
play four games in it don't always wanna
hear a pitch twice yeah 11 games in 6
days well yes
question number 33 I think NASA is blank
hmm hiding things from us yeah so sake
um the space agency that is hiding
things from us big name a baby team work
on those they a bunch of [ __ ] lies
you guys allow your dogs arket all right
question number 34 when I was little I
used to walk down to the bathroom and
say I'll see you in blank who are you
talking to
hey listen this one talked to herself
and she was her favorite audience so
that's how long nothing's changed right
well I gotta take this because I've
already told that I really know so I
have to pretend that yeah yeah you're
walked in here seeing flora see in
Florida and now I go every year to
playlist love day in day out breakfast
and shot at sea and flora if you
asked my eight-year-old self what my
bucket list was it's just going to
Florida one time oh my god you're living
out your dream every year mm-hmm okay
the last question question number five
what's the most disappointed I've ever
been and this is a trick question
it's a trick clean I'll see my trick
you're not going to get it you're not
going to get the awesome rich G what do
you think the most disappointed I've
ever been is amol yet Jake relish I mean
there's a new answer as of this time
most disappointment it's a trick
question
show me just tell you yeah yeah so you
remember when we went to polar like
finally for the first time right yeah
and we went and saw that Michael Jackson
3d exhibit show we finally got there
after all those years of me walking down
the stairs go ahead I'll see you in
Florida cuz I just wanted to go to
Florida one time we went to the like
Universal or whatever they had this 3d
Michael Jackson show we all had our 3d
glasses and do you remember what I'm
talking about
I don't it was like a 3d Michael Jackson
video he was like dancing and stuff it
wasn't a ride it was just like a show
but it was like the first time that they
had 3d glasses technology to see things
so it was really special and he's like
doing his song and video is a big thing
that we're just standing there watching
it and so I take my glasses off to see
what it looked like without the glasses
on and as I go like this and pull them
off to see everything I'm such a funny
story
my dad don't know what it looks I don't
know what it was I don't know what I
miss it everyone was like oh it's like
the loudest crowd gasps I've ever heard
oh you menace to have I feel really bad
I'm so sad after all these years of
being like man I can't wait it's going
to be like the trip of a lifetime the
one moment that it culminated her
glasses off
you remember went how bad I wanted to
see the Phantom of the Opera on Toronto
and then we finally went and we were
like we had amazing seats like under
like where the chandelier would come to
like swing down and I'm sitting there I
think I was 6 when we saw there's no
more between 6 and 8 and I remember
saying to my six year old self I
remember the dress I was wearing I
remember everything and I was so like I
literally remember sitting in my seat
and being like I'm gonna remember this
for the rest of my life I am at the
Phantom of the Opera right now and the
chandelier which and it was like and
Here I am girl I remember it yeah oh
it's so sweet the most disappointed I
have been I was actually really adorable
stories I just want to know what that
video is I want to see it delivered ok
hon and everyone who anyone who is there
don't tell her the work nobody like went
like this is his glove or like a jacket
something like jump it was like the
pinnacle of the ship and you guys how I
reached out yeah I yeah Amanda Ober the
look seven evening one mmm
we all just get a participation award
maybe I took part of my heart in the
event Gillian Joey I think anybody'll
into this podcast get some parts of you
guys you guys you guys get making it
this far
[Laughter]
relish and if you've made it this far
maybe just comment somewhere in the
comments but spell debbie de b y and
just insist that's how their yeah
exactly but yeah thank you guys for
hanging on with us for another so Debbie
thank you for joining us it was
wonderful happy Mother's Day Mother's
Day even though you tried to throw the
game with the Jake birthday um thank you
to all the things Sam who wish me a
happy Mother's Day
oh don't mind the shows me you guys are
so sweet you know you guys I love you
little bit thank you so you guys have a
great week we'll see you another one
later
[Music]
[Music]